hey paul um
it's been getting worse um
you made me promise to uh to call if i
ever started making plans and i guess
this is
that call i don't know anyway uh
i'm i'm so sorry to ruin your saturday
um
you know i'm just starting to think that
maybe this isn't a phase
maybe this is just
what what it feels like
to be me
i can understand that feeling
like i've had like uh
and lou gehrig's disease i i could just
decide to just
you know not keep going and and that
might
that kind of that might be the right
decision
right
i could just i could just say you know
enough's enough
i'm sorry
you don't need to be sorry
oh man
is it okay for me to tell you that i
believe in you
and that i care about you
is that okay
because i do
i think that when you feel this way it's
important that you just live in the
moment
and you don't start storytelling okay
resist the temptation to convert your
feelings into
this dismal future
come on
no
uh i'm sorry about that um
he's fine by the way you know him
let's just get back to the session
so
um
that feeling
you know the bleak feeling
of
feeling overwhelmed right when that
when that happens i think it's important
that you
you read it registers like what it feels
like here in your body
does that make sense
oh what what the [ __ ]
you you you need to
go back home we can talk about this at
home you need to leave now that's
[ __ ] i'm sorry david no it's okay
what
not you
his name is david too yes
jesus christ
you you promised me that you would come
so come on you listen you haven't been
to a single wrestling meet this entire
season
you have to go now okay you have to go
it's time
please sit it's okay no no sit it's fine
yes
this is an emergency situation i'm an
emergency situation i freaking biked
here
david
i'm with a patient
okay you're being thoughtless okay
what's his emergency
you look good you're just sitting there
uh well you know lately i've been
feeling a lot like don't say anything
you you don't have to say anything um
well i people
i didn't realize that i was making you
miss you don't have to apologize it's
not your fault how about you just come
with me
and then you come back after you talk to
him it's not like he's going to suddenly
stop being depressed okay i mean that's
what i was saying okay you know what how
about we take a deep breath i've always
calmed down no no my match is in half an
hour david
i am so sorry can you do me the biggest
favor and step outside i need to talk to
my son i think i should just like go
home and and uh you should you should go
to the meet yeah thank you i'm sorry
you're feeling um shitty no no thanks
man don't go home don't go home let him
go he wants to go no he can't go
do not go sit in that chair
david please i'm advising you all right
are you are you are you angry with me
i'm not angry at you i'm not angry at
either of you
i'm not
i'm not angry with you okay
all right are you angry with anyone no
fine let's go
hold on
i love you
but i can't come to your match right now
i get dibs
what i get first dibs he might be sad
i'm sorry but you and mom had sex and
now i exist so i [ __ ] get dibs
he could give you 150 bucks an hour but
i am your son well i mean i paid 200
actually it's a sliding scale right this
is the biggest match in my entire life
you have wrestled for only a year well i
am wrestling
andy [ __ ] doing
who is andy doing he is a beast he is
the greatest [ __ ] animal that there
is he looks like he's 40 years old and
he doesn't shower and he smells like the
bread at jersey mike's that's terrible
yes
they call him the hoagie and dad
i'm gonna pin him okay
i'm gonna pee in the hoagie
and i want you to see that
i mean well i mean if there's any
consolation i i threatened to to kill
myself and you're dead the only person
who's gonna die today as andy [ __ ]
don't
watch what you're saying
sorry
i know suicide is uh
serious but i'm i'm really i'm really
keyed up right now i understand listen
i know this is disappointing but we all
have to make sacrifices
and i don't think you can imagine
the severity of what this guy's going
through
this is a serious business all right but
there are other people who have it worse
than he does you're not qualified to
make that statement there's a french guy
isis shoved a grenade up his [ __ ]
what are you talking about i saw a video
of it on ebon's world it's uh so i i saw
that video it's that's not real
you watch that you tell me that's not
real that's like the realest [ __ ]
thing i've seen in my entire life
he explodes [ __ ] first then his
middle then his face jesus christ david
so you got what i'm saying
you have to no no
i'm kidding please you have to
oh my god
you are acting like a child
come on no david i appreciate your
patience here
get off me
get off me
what's the matter with you
do you have any idea what you're doing
i could lose my license
he could severely hurt himself
do you ever think about what you're
doing i have to work david
i have to put you through college
i'll get a wrestling scholarship
no you won't you barely made the team
sorry
i
i didn't mean i just
think you're a good dad
but you're not
you're not a good dad
you know david
in relationships
people sometimes say things that
can never be taken back
they can apologize
they can even be forgiven but some
things
once they are said
that poison is released
into the ecosystem of that relationship
and it can never be recovered
he said
is that true
up
shake hands
[Applause]
all right
you're good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh